Our next guest is Vukosi Marivate, who is currently a graduate student in computer science.
He studies machine learning, but he's also a keen observer of the impact
of technology on world cultures.
He's been in several technology companies,
and he's going to share some of his experiences with us.
We have with us Vukosi Marivate.
Vukosi lives in South Africa, and he's currently going to graduate school
in the United States to get his PhD in computer science.
He has interned at a number of different companies,
and this summer he interned with a company called Meebo
that does some social networking.
Can you tell me a little bit about Meebo?
What is it that they have been doing and where are they now?
[Vukosi Marivate, Graduate Student, Rutgers University]
Meebo was a company that did a couple of things.
One was that they had a chat app.
Another is that they also did advertising through something called Meebo bar.
They also then had a new product that was being developed
to give you news, so you would actually log into the service,
put up what your interests are, and you would either be friends with other people on the network,
and from there would actually mine the data that's created by all these people
to actually now give you news and information that's relevant to you.
Do you have a sense of what sort of algorithmic work they had to do
to support their company?
In most cases when you're looking at networks,
the things that are very interesting to do first
are dead simple ways to actually recommend who people should be friends with.
This goes across the spectrum whether you're on Facebook,
on Linked In, on Twitter, or Meebo, and Google+.
The other things that become more interesting is finding out who's important in a graph.
This is actually not as simple as just looking at who has the most connections.
Either has the most followers or the most friends and things like that,
but actually be who is the person where information flows through.
There are algorithms that try to actually do this,
and people are developing them using different metrics
to try to figure out who's important given a topic, let's say.
Finding out who is very important given ice cream in California.
Those kinds of problems normally require you to do
some mathematical modeling of the networks that you have.
Do you have a sense of what a really simple example of an algorithm might be
that would determine importance? Maybe not what people are really doing.
But something related to it.
One could be looking at giving keywords that people use.
Given who uses those keywords, and then looking at if a person uses that keyword,
who then after that shares that keyword more and more.
Just looking at something that's called a "cascade"--
how information moves through a network,
but if you can look at the origin of where that keyword started
and see how fast it grows, maybe, or how many people it gets to,
you can then go back to figuring out who then is important.
So, if you can figure out, let's say, who is important in burgers, right,
then you could then target advertising towards that person.
You're advertising your product, and if they spread it, then you can then get to more people.
So, it's different to advertising a burger to me.
I probably don't have a lot of people who follow me because of my knowledge of burgers.
But there could be other people out there who people follow because of their information,
so if you can figure out who those people are, then you can advertise to them,
and they can spread information.
I did a project at Rutgers where it tried to figure out
who was important given an edu-tainment TV show.
In this case, I was trying to found out who was important in trying to spread information about HIV.
In this case, it was not advertising but it's actually very important
in educating people.
If you can figure out who spreads that information well,
you get to more people and you can have more impact.
That seems really important--yeah.
I mean, not just--all over the world, right?
There's these issues that are taking place.
What's your sense of what social networks are like in other countries outside the United States?
Is it similar to the way it is here or are there variations?
Because of differing bandwidth constraints,
you have some social networks more used in some countries than others.
You have countries that use Twitter, because it's very easy.
To get on it's very low bandwidth, and also it spreads information very quickly.
More quickly than Facebook, and it's open.
Obviously, everybody knows about the Arab Spring now,
and Twitter was very pivotal in that.
In some countries there are other social networks that are very big there.
They might not be big in the United States.
In South Africa and some of most of Africa use something called "Mxit"--M-X-I-T,
which is based in South Africa. It was created there.
It has a huge user base in South Africa.
I think Orchid is still very big in South America,
which isn't quite as big as Google, but it's still spreading.
Just locally it's very big there.